In this lesson we'll be talking about network measurement, or how to see what
traffic is being sent on the network.
There are two types of network measurement. One
is passive measurement. In passive measurement we
collect packets, flow statistics, and so forth of
traffic that is already being sent on
the network. So, this might include packet traces,
flow statistics, or application level logs.
In active measurement, we inject additional traffic
into the network to measure various characteristics
of the network. So we've seen some
examples of active measurement already, such
as in the previous lessons, where we
actively sent traffic on the network to
measure speeds of downloads. Other common active
measurement tools include those such as ping, and traceroute. Ping
is often used to measure the delay to a particular server.
And traceroute is often used to measure the network level,
or the IP level path between two hosts on the network.